each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I would say so I'm today I'm going to
talk about Sakura just over a network
fob us privacy protecting communication
has been secured both mine
Foreign Press
so first of all along explain what the
issues are anonymous communication
three parties Ellis for 13 and so the
first aspect expensive it is and i will
see what anonymity
and the second one will be the unlink
ability so Eve as a third party should
not learn that actually Alice and Bob
are communicating the third aspect of
anonymous communication is also location
independent so the network position for
Alice and Bob should not be clear to any
of the three parties also basically the
goals that we want to achieve to make a
system really secure and robust for
privacy so problem number one in this
whole work is the traffic analysis so if
this one computer communicates with the
other computer actually everybody could
see the path to the network secondly we
could actually measure this end delay of
the packets to the end we need the two
ends and the network could have a global
or partial adversary's or the it was we
could control a large number of nodes or
just a small number of nodes and typical
traffic analysis methods would be just
like timing analysis you will just
measure the entire packet I'm just count
the number of packets that go through
these intermediate nodes the second
problem we face in in this whole area is
software bugs so somebody could recruit
a large botnet and basically start
monitoring traffic and you becomes a
much more powerful adversary than it
used to be before and so these problems
are related to software bugs were birds
of makes it possible for anniversary to
compromise a large number of nodes and
to get more powerful traffic analysis so
basically infects these pcs and recruits
them as botnets we accumulate these
botnets
in the anonymity network and raise the
number of nodes for traffic analysis and
additional protection against software
bug that also makes the system more
robust against traffic analysis so to
face these two issues on I have set up
this talk by first looking at how we can
use trusted computing to do that the
second one would be hard to do when talk
about traffic analysis what are the
various traffic analysis attacks and how
to protect against them then I talked
about the design of stone and last I
present the results so the first thing
or the most common thing in in traffic
analysis protection are mix networks so
a mix network is basically collection of
nodes and so all messages go through all
of these nodes is basically a cascade so
they are basically and messages over
here and they go through all these
stages of the mixes and having mix
shuffles these messages in a random
order and sends them out again in the
first basically every sender has to
encrypt in layers as shown here but is
public keys of the various mixes before
they actually get inserted into the
network and then every not just strips
of a layer shuffles the northern
messages steps of the next layer and so
on so we get some kind of a random order
of the messages here but all these
intermediate nodes don't know what the
what the order is because they don't
know what the plain text messages nor do
they know where the nodes come from when
I go to so the problem is this is
actually from software parks so if if
the adversary control several of these
mixes
he would actually learn how these
messages get distributed so you could
correlate things like message size or
timing then a scalability and resilience
are difficult so if one of these mixes
fails we need to reorganize the whole
mix network to basically do the Cascade
just without this one node and every
node who is sending has to know all the
public keys or in advance then there's
an additional latency for shuffling on
every mix because I remix he has to get
a certain number of messages until it
makes sense to protect against traffic
analysis and if there's only one message
traveling through the whole mix network
it's basically useless and the last one
is there's no receiver anonymity so
sender has to know who is sending to so
he has to know all the public keys along
the path so Alice always knows who
bothers and this mix network so coming
to trusted computing we're there are
several ideas and how we can actually
use trusted computing to improve your
situation so we have this thing between
untrusted processes and trusted
processes and this is basically
architecture how I assume trusted
computing is going to be it as a smaller
trusted corner that can be easily
verified and as an untrusted corner that
sits on top of the trusted corner so
these two trusted processes are
basically isolated from these untrusted
processes and the idea is that if an
advisory compromises one of these
untrusted processes he cannot infect one
of these trusted processes that would be
used for for the network routing
so in the second advantage is because
you have remote at the station so we can
make sure that every node runs the same
version of the software and we can
induce some kind of affair stop
semantics as compared to a Byzantine
semantics so either we know all the
vulnerabilities that means we can assume
that the notes either crash or whether
they live work but there's no real
malicious behavior and that's that's one
of the main advantages because the
malicious behavior would induced it the
note would actually monitor our traffic
arbitrarily so just to give a quick
comparison of failed stop versus
byzantine semantics byzantine semantics
we have traitors in the system there's
any kind of malicious software possible
like viruses and worms it's actually
very difficult to detect a synchronously
because this simply we cannot we don't
know whether or not actually hangs over
at sending messages to their various
protocols and in the literature that try
to solve this problem but there are not
very good in performance the first stop
semantics is typically affair stop
processors we simply restart the system
and it is actually no harm to the system
it only crashes and then restarts
so in terms of also I should probably
add in terms of a botnet if you had an
affair stop semantics would not be
possible to recruit a botnet off no it's
as compared to Byzantine semantics so
the trusted overlay Network we want to
authenticate anonymously to peer node
already authenticated notes basically
run the same software these
authenticated nodes have to have some
common shared secret because otherwise
anybody could join the network and
potentially money to other traffic then
we use the failed stock model instead of
a Byzantine for model and it protects
against compromises from these botnets
because of the Pharaoh mode so basically
what we get at the end is as a whole
network I just have trusted computing
bases on them and all these notes
authenticate to each other or not
necessary to each other depending on a
network topology
so now we come to secure and trusted ola
networks so one thing is we want to
protect against traffic analysis that's
the main goal of the work that's the one
issue is that has to be scalable has to
be a large anonymous crowd more nodes we
have that it is the easier it is to to
heighten messages the second is the
sender receiver anonymity as mentioned
earlier was obvious three traffic
analysis requirements so we want to hide
to send us in the receivers in a network
you want to hide the connections in the
network and you also want to make the
notes independent of the location and
the internet order geographical location
and the second part would basically be
trust we do want to have trusted sockets
so application endpoints that are
protected from an adversary and not like
sockets that can be compromised as we
would have right now if if the if the
socket is basically if the machine is
compromised and also socket is
compromised so the applications don't
have to deal with these problems anymore
and the other thing is we want to have
one-to-one certificates instead of one
to end certificates because if it would
publish a very signed certificate then
everybody would know that this person is
actually microsoft.com but that's not
what everybody should know so an
otherwise the anonymity is is
compromised there should be a
certificate that only says Ellis only
publishes to Bob that she is actually
Ellis and not to anybody else
so now we come to all these traffic
analysis at text that stone has to
protect against so basically the first
part is the predecessor attack strong
here that's very well known attack in
the literature where notes in the system
analyze the predecessor of the messages
and so the whole idea is that the sender
is always always in the path between the
sender and the receiver but all the
other nodes are don't have a such a high
probability of being in the path so just
by analyzing the predecessor the message
can deduce that somebody must be the
center the second one would be the
timing analysis so two different nodes
measure into a packet times and they
conclude can conclude whether they're on
the same path some probability the third
is basically network tomography so
somebody could just measure and to end
delays in the network from our various
nodes and he controls and then did you
is what the individual link latencies
are and what the neighbor relations on
and last there is the intersection
attack so if somebody measures the
traffic volume and so constrained
topology in order for connected network
then he can indeed it induce some
relations between the path and I'm going
to explain this in more detail
especially the predecessor attack first
so we have a network where we have
limited number of nodes compromised a
three in this case and
there is the traffic from the sender to
the receiver in this case it just
selects one path it's basically random
walk then we select another path and
that happens to be on the on the on the
path with this one compromised notes
that is compromised no knows the IP
address and the connection ID for this
connection between s and R then the next
one would be the another compromised not
so we would also learn the IP address of
the sender and then we would pick a
whole different path and then so this
guy would learn that his predecessor is
actually this guy and then we pick
another path and then this guy would
again see this one as a predecessor but
just a statistical probability says that
this note is actually more likely to see
s on the path because as is to send on s
is always on the path so he sees this
one IP address very often and therefore
he can lead use that this one must be
either close to the Sun or the high
probability Peterson okay so the idea is
basically to use trusted computing to
protect against this attack simply
because we have strong process isolation
and remote at a station and the network
secret of it we we cannot do any logical
packet sniffing on the network so any
advisory would be an untrusted process
wouldn't see incoming IP addresses on
ass trusted process the only way to
actually do it is to do a physical
packet sniffing on the network so you
have to control the notes physically and
not through a button it
the weakness of course is that the
network secret and the trusted computing
base are kind of a single point of
failure so if the trusted computing base
gets compromised which is usually hard
to do then you could actually still
monitor all these predecessor IP
addresses and the in addition if the
network secret leaks meaning that you
can authenticate to any network and very
powerful adversary could actually just
penetrate the network and also do this
predecessor text so the notes the tecum
controls physically
so the second point is basically a
timing analysis so if you have still
have these three compromised notes the
first node receives a certain timing
pattern of packets and second now it
also receives the same timing pattern
off packets then these two nodes can
conclude that they're on the same path
basically we use random routing to
protect against this timing analysis and
random routing is valiant style routing
from workstation clusters so I'm going
to explain the next slide or exactly it
works the only weaknesses that it
creates lots of out of water packets
because packets get different delays
through the network and every packet has
to traverse the network twice basically
so random routing see you on the next
slide every note basically picks a
random intermediate node and forwards
the message to this random intermediate
node in this random intermediate node
for what's the message to the receiver
and then the receiver sends it back via
another different intermediate node in
this way we actually balance the traffic
across the network but since we do is be
too we are the intermediate node there's
some additional cost so the packet that
he has in the worst case traverse the
network two times
so the third attack is not network
tomography network tomography we do this
pings from between two random nodes in
the network and then pick a different
one in at the end we want to know what
are these latency is of between the
nodes and saw the ideas to conclude
properties about the actual network
topology if you know the network
topology and just given any any
end-to-end delay we can some probability
predict what the path was to the network
so then in addition we to to actually
protect against this attack we shuffled
in network nodes this actually creates
additional latency some shorter
distances but it's also Network
tomography problem so for example if you
had this normal geographic layout of
cities in the internet basically
assigned some random address and order
to this according to this random address
in the network so that audion Ava
relations gets offered so Anna last
traffic analysis attack is basically the
intersection of tech in the intersection
attack the problem is that the sender
who talks to the receiver takes
different despite its taking different
paths or the network nodes that are
closer to the sender in a constrained
network topology actually have more
traffic on their links as compared to
notes that are somewhere in the middle
of the network
and using this attack we have this
problem of unbalanced traffic volumes
and this partially connected network so
that any note would determine how close
it is actually to descend or the
receiver and this is important when the
network topology is known especially if
the tomography attack would succeed so
the only way stone can actually protect
against this kind of attack sunstone
gives us a limited network topology is
to balance the center eight across the
network so for every node has to send
approximately the same rate which
creates additional cover traffic and
slows don't send us on the other hand so
if there's a network like the red nodes
are sending at a higher rate and yellow
nodes we can actually balance the
traffic across a network so that they
all get even out and the synchronization
actually also benefits from random
routing because simply every note isn't
intermediate node in the network every
note in the network roughly knows what
the approximate traffic volume is that
goes through the network can basically
adapt to this rate
so when are we come to the stone design
so what does the overlay look like if
you take a pair of nodes so this is
basically the stone architecture between
these two nodes and the first component
of this architecture would be the stone
proxy this Don proxy sets up TCP
connections to a different stone proxy
on a different note and on top it
communicates with a router basically
adds like a firewall between the network
and the router and makes also sure that
you do the handshake TCP handshake and
the key exchange doing initialization on
top of this stone proxy have the router
and Tarata is actually a test to another
when you the remote attestation
including the stone foxy on top of the
router we have the applications that may
actually be trusted or untrusted they
can attest voluntarily or not but it
wouldn't compromise the security of the
nerve the transport system so only these
apps can communicate via stone sockets
to the router
so we now look at the router you see
that they get the tip tip tip oh right
the socket to the application and
communicate to the proxy using new stone
connections and so the whole idea of the
stone routing is to maximize the number
of nodes in stone so we use a structured
overlay to do this and it's off the
problem for scalability for a neighbor
our discovery and also minimize number
of handshakes so he would have a full
connected network as lots of this
typical anonymity networks are right now
we'd have to exchange keys with our
neighbors when and you know joints for
example in tour every node has to learn
what every other node so it's basically
a static proxy Network but this way we
don't have to to rely on a static proxy
Network but can be dynamic so any node
who's participating in the network can
also forward traffic so the weaknesses
of this of course are that link failures
break path and because the constraint
network structure there's also a lot
imbalance so one not can have higher
bandwidth and another node and this node
and actually become a bottleneck in the
network
so for example the structured overlay in
general use a hypercube architecture so
if the 011 sends a packet to 100 it
actually compares bitwise and sets the
bits accordingly to forward this packet
to the correct position so first it
looks at the first bit sets of 21 then
the second bit sets to 0 in the 3rd so
it always takes log n steps to forward
this message sunstone we use a random
hypercube topology the stone address is
a 64-bit hash of the trusted computing
secret key so nobody can actually
duplicate any node IDs in stone which is
also a problem that's this cyber at
civil attack where every peer-to-peer
not just gets a new node ID and if you
get lots of not ideas you can easily
compromised our network in addition the
base in the hypercube determines to path
length so if you only have base for you
would have locked for and on path length
and routing table size
on the fee so if it's the base becomes
very large the network would become
fully connected which is the trade-off
in this case different it's all so
different from deep to send out
distributed hash tables simply because
if to optimize for alternative routes
instead of replicas that's not like
finding a an object for a key but it's
finding what is the best route to the
network for this receiver and random
routing requires load balancing so in a
normal distributed hash table with you
don't care how long it actually takes to
get to the destination but in random
routing you want to have a short round
trip time and if there's a bottleneck
node in between we need to do something
about it so basically what stone does it
uses k virtual addresses for load
balancing so the more higher bandwidth a
note has more about your addresses that
just gets and it just has more hyper
cube at rosies available in this
hypercube at this additional hypercube
address these are just the hash of the
previous address so it's like a whole
hair shade and it's easily verifiable
that this additional or just note didn't
acquire any illegal addresses for the
routing we use the longest common prefix
because it's a random address and not
all the notes in a hypercube may be
available so we have to route through
some gaps basically so if this is the
note address then in this destination
address veggie forwards to slot number
three because this is the longest common
prefix
in addition we use entries per slot to
improve resilience so every node has two
alternatives if one link is broken it
just sends the packet or the message to
to the next to the second choice and
actually given the probabilities in the
internet we can assume that there's an
availability between 95 and 100 percent
so we even increase the number of nodes
in stone significantly we still with two
choices we get an almost equivalent or
path probability or path correctness
probability notice path failure
probability as comparable to the
internet itself so or this is still fine
so next you want to look at these
applications they basically use stone
sockets which is a standard library that
gets linked to the applications to
communicate with these routers the
problem with today's applications are as
you've seen in Internet Explorer these
days is the teaching attacks are common
and web browsers nowadays have
precautions or some measures against the
phishing attacks also there's website
spoofing and malware gets gets installed
and even the courts keyboard inputs so
it's getting nastier and nastier the
second issue is that certificates reveal
the identities and destroy anonymity
week and also use certificates simply if
Bob will just have a very signed
certificate why do we do the whole
anonymity
thing anyway because everybody would
know that he's Bob so it has to be some
kind of a different choice for
certificates similar to what has been
done in email pseudonyms like the early
email anonymous email issues where you
will just get similar to AOL Instant
Messenger will just get a pseudonym that
nobody really knows publicly but only
your friends would know so the first
example applications that we have is
like an instant messenger application
the problem is architecture right now is
that as a centralized instant messenger
server and everybody connects to this
instant messengers over and the
interesting thing is that there are lots
of counter anonymous or not really
privacy protecting policies so if you
look at AOL Instant Messenger they
explicitly say they can record any
messages that go through this instant
messenger and nobody can actually
control what he wants to reveal or what
he doesn't want to review so there's
basically central certification and
central anonymization and we want to
distribute this because now we have this
nice infrastructure with the structure
overlay how are we going to do this so
that's what I'm going to explain in the
next example is the clover fire system
so if there are if there's a global file
system like SF s where file axis is
certified but not anonymous so people
know that they actually access the right
server because the public key is
contained in the server path and the
other option is basically published
subscribe to the file exists
it's anonymous but it's not certified
similar to what all these peer-to-peer
networks use or even free net so
basically we can use down to solve this
problem and combine anonymity with
certification so the stone API basically
has stolen sockets which are similar to
TCP UDP sockets just that the socket
addresses are opaque capabilities so
that is a huge random string that
doesn't tell the user anything about the
application of the application about the
network then we have application
specific random strings so even if you
have even if you know the random string
for one application and for another
application they just don't correlate at
all so we cannot say these two
applications are talking to the same so
ever
and secondly we have to deal with all
these problems of out of order packets
and random routing so they have to be
standard transfer protocols over stone
that uses pc provides flow control and
packet reordering and we don't have to
use congestion control and it will
actually be not be good in the
architecture to use it since we already
have congestion avoidance by using
random rotting so if there's really a
congestion there's no way to walk around
in the network because it's just
exhausted the the whole bandwidth of the
network and then the second big
component mr. trusted name service so we
have to find a way to map these opaque
predicates to some name so if you want
to look up Ellis wants to look at Bob
she should get away to find the opaque
capability of Bob and we use public keys
as a certification mechanism basically
similar to what other approaches like SF
s do just to explain a scenario of
distrust that name services so he say
Ellis Ellis wants to publish identity or
is it create some kind of certificate
for Bob so she registers with a trusted
name servers and she says registering
chat with the key of Alice the public
key of Ellis then the trusted name
service challenges Alice with us
business public key so she sends
basically a string that she should
encrypt and and she confirms that the
land Bob also does the same thing with
this public key and we get the challenge
and then Alice gets the public key of
Bob through some off line channel
and then she uses this public key of Bob
to vary the name service entry and then
the names are just response was
capability and the capability is
actually not global so the trusted name
service basically embeds some string
into the capability string into the
packet and the local trust the computing
system analysis side basically encrypts
it for her to a session so this is but
this capability cannot be intercepted
because it's encrypted over the network
so only trusted computing system itself
then converts it into procession
capabilities and finally Alice uses this
capability to connect to Bob so instead
of using an IP address and report just
uses this capability so to solve us
these two problems I've explained
basically the instant messenger in this
example so every party registers a
public key with it tested names of us
and the PS connect using stone sockets
and secondly you have a trusted global
file system the Abbey fire has a public
key on the trusted name service and if
you want to download this file basically
add us just gets the public key for the
certain fire and requests the capability
for the fire from the name service and
then you download and upload the file
using stone sockets the problem of the
names I was of course is that has to be
replicated throughout the network if
it's just this one note that carries the
name service happens to go down then
system would be compromised
so um that's that's the only issue so
right now on the whole stone
implementation is about 10,000 lines of
c code and use the plan labs for
large-scale experiments we simulated
trusted computing on planet lab- stay
open SSL crypto library there's a to
userspace process solution right now so
this is done proxy and router that are
located in different spaces and it uses
a synchronous i/o and pipes with confer
communication between the processes and
as a watchdog process just in case one
process crashes and has to be restarted
right now performance has not been
optimized simply because planetlab
doesn't allow to load up any kernel
modules and forwarding messages through
user space is incredibly slow so it will
see basically have to copy every single
packet for every on every hop from
corner space to user space and back into
Chronos space just to get an idea on how
does TCB works on planetlab so we have
the whole store ass with a fling rocks
and then there's the Linux visa is the
virtual server implementation and
vserver basically provides a whole linux
OS with root access but it's limited
because it's not a real virtual machine
it's more like a user space and
Malaysian so we cannot really modify the
corner and so the tcby see me sits on
top of the OS right now and the
application that's on top of the TCP so
the TCB basically that's the TCP
handshake and the key exchange and
remote at the station
and has to be in that order so that the
channel is actually encrypted before the
remote attestation takes place
so the baseline performance is just a
micro benchmarks you set up to machines
and forward messages forth and back so
we have different fragment or message
sizes if it's 512 I basically contrast
or compare the stone performance to an
ICMP ping or this is an echo server
which is useless base then you have to
stow and without any encryption and
stolen that is encrypted so ICMP this
flat for basically every packet size it
has the same almost the same ron shipp
time because doesn't have to copy any
data between you some space in kono
space so the echo server in the user
space already has some increased delay
because it has to copy data forth and
back and if you add encryption or store
and it's only as very tiny overhead
right now using our to process solution
so that's pretty much what you would get
additionally we did some measurements in
writing to have a size with 64 notes on
stone so the measured versus the
expected routing table size this would
be log n what we would get with some
constants simply because we use to
virtual addresses for note and we use
two slots for entry so you have
something like four times log N and yeah
this is the the measured
rotting table size so it's actually
pretty much what you would expect if we
hash the addressee
so the SEC next slide would be the
distance between the stone notes so you
have 64 notes on Planet lab and we
measure the number of hops between notes
and in this case it's basically the peak
at two nodes since the nodes are
contained random addresses there's also
a random distance but the majority
actually has only two hops and this is
also feels random routing we wouldn't
get more than four hops in between the
two nodes which is still acceptable then
the last experiment is to measure the
round trip times between two nodes on in
the sequence so basically do a ping
across the whole network and measure the
round trip times in these round trip
times are by normally distributed so
depending on how many hops it takes
through network we get a shorter or
longer round-trip time and random
routing pretty much random my system all
right time if you will just do a normal
ICMP thing or the round trip times would
be unjust bottom line basically
and we actually also get so I should add
a pretty high absolute value just
because we have an optimized the
performance issues with the users best
to Colonel space copying so it would
probably do much better in the future
let's implemented the synchronous stone
basically eight notes on a linux server
and we have once and now receive a prsn
data flow rate so we get ramped up to a
certain throughput over time which
basically shows how the synchronization
succeed so the idea is to have all the
sender's in the networks and
approximately at the same rate but also
shouldn't ramp up too quickly because if
if there would happen then the whole
system would basically oscillate and we
would increase ones then write the other
one would go down and the other one
would go down too much and then
basically end up in this viet state so
conclusions basically what we did is we
we fix this problem of software box so
we have fair stop semantics that would
require physical access to compromise
nodes then we use the structured overlay
that improve scalability and resilience
we maximize the notes for assistance
against traffic analysis by using the
structured overlay because we can have
lots of nods and knots can enter and
leave and it's not a fixed set of nodes
that could be compromised
the second one a start point is
basically random rotting you have to
self mixing property that hides the the
link ability between sender and receiver
so the order of the packets is
completely random random routing we have
the self timing property that basically
means that every node knows how much
traffic there has to be in the network
and basic can determine its own xandred
then synchronization is basically the
full protection against the intersection
attacks if the advisory happens to know
something about the network structure
and even without synchronization just
don't a step more powerful than mixes
because it can protect against timing
attacks and it's porn also protects
against scalability and resilience that
would otherwise be a problem yep and
that's the talk
thank you I learned a lot of photos a
great pop good
yeah that's a tricky business anonymity